joining us now president biden's chief
medical advisor on the covet crisis
dr anthony fauci dr fauci good afternoon
welcome to america reports glad to have
you here
good to be with you thank you for having
me first off this new strain we're just
talking to our audience about it
how deadly is it are we able to detect
it
and is it growing in numbers well which
one are you talking about uh because i
just sat down are you talking about the
south african one
that's the problem which one okay so
let's start with the uk let's start with
south africa what do we need to be
worried about
as americans what is here right now well
we need to take it very seriously but
the uk
strain which is one that has a certain
set of mutations
is already in 25 or more states in the
united states
it has been shown according to the work
that were done by our colleagues in the
uk
to be more transmissible namely more
easy to transmit
they at first had said that it was not
more lethal namely that it didn't cause
on a person-to-person basis more serious
disease
but just this past week they came out
with some new data
which indicates that the uk strain might
in fact
be a bit more deadly than what we call
the wild-type strain
with regard to the vaccines that we're
using
there does not seem to be any negative
impact on the ability
of the vaccine to be able to protect
against the uk strain
it's a bit of a different story with
regard to the strain that is now
dominant
in south africa because a number of the
monoclonal antibodies
that have been used for treatment and
prevention don't work as well against
that strain
it has diminished somewhat
the capability of the vaccine to protect
butt and this is an important but the
vaccine
still is effective against this strain
that is in south africa having said that
we need to try and stay
a few steps ahead of the game so we are
already preparing
in case that mutant a gets here which it
might already be here
but in case it gets documented to be
here and mutates a bit more
to evade the protection of the vaccine
we need to be prepared
to upgrade the vaccine to allow it
to be able to protect but right now the
vaccines
look fine against both the uk
and the south africa strain dr fauci
you said in the last couple of days that
when it comes to the vaccine
supply will not meet the demand which is
language that's a lot different
than what we saw just a few minutes
months ago in the closing days of the
trump
administration you were part of it back
then i don't want to go back and rehash
the trump administration but what i
would like to know is
was there a number of months ago a
comprehensive plan developed by the
white house
to distribute this vaccine because a
former obama administration
is saying that things were a mess when
the biden administration took over if
they if they were
a mess you were part of that team so
what was in place at that time
yeah well john i really don't want to go
back and rehash that that is not
productive one of the things that part
of operation warp speed was
a plan to be able to get vaccine in what
uh general perna gus perna who was in
charge of that
get it out in a cadence of getting the
vaccine out
getting it shipped getting it
distributed and getting it into the
places
where it was supposed to be in the
beginning there were some
missteps there because there was a
discrepancy about what was being
determined to go out and what was
getting into people's
arms so right now what we're trying to
do is to get
a broader plan but a lot of a lot of
good things did happen with operation
warp speed
during those months several months ago
right now let's look forward
about what the president president biden
has said
how we're going to try and get as many
doses into as many people as all
as quickly as we possibly can and that's
why he has his plan
which i want to emphasize is a flaw
not a ceiling to get a hundred million
doses
into people in the first hundred days dr
fatchi on that note it
boggles many when you see some of the
decisions that state that governors are
making
on closures and here in new york new
york city the positivity rates drop
below one percent
almost 75 percent of hospital workers
have received the vaccine
but yet the governor has not indicated
that he's going to reopen restaurants
for
in-person dining as you have
acknowledged
this is incredible pain on small
businesses restaurant tours
that can't operate their businesses
inside when it's 20 degrees and snowing
out
do you see any reason why the new york
governor shouldn't
allow for in-person dining to reopen
with those statistics
you know i have to tell you i'm not
going to be out here out-guessing
a governor who is on the ground in his
or home but those are statistics
yeah i mean no no we're not going to go
there
i'm not going to be out guessing
individually so you don't want to go
there but what about school closures
chicago won't reopen their schools i
mean you've talked about
kids are not passing this disease inside
the classrooms when they're
following cdc guidelines so shouldn't
they reopen schools in chicago for
example
well what i'm going to tell you are the
general principles
and each individual state with their
governor
city with their mayor will make their
own decisions the first thing
i would let me just finish let me just
comment and see if i could
if i could help you out please to be
able to understand the bigger picture
that yes i understand greatly the strain
that is on local businesses and
restaurants and others
that that's the reason why we need help
we need to be able to get resources
that if indoor dining is going to be
prohibited
we've got to have help to the owners of
those organizations
so that they don't go under during a
period of time
when we're trying to correct and get our
arms around
this is supposed to be following the
science and i think that's the problem
does the science say that kids can
safely be back in the classroom that
they're following cdc guidance
what the what the science tells us is
the following
that children in school right now it
appears that if you follow
the safety guidelines of the cdc
that they are less likely to be getting
infected
than the community rate of infection and
that's the reason why
as president biden has said we're going
to try as best as we can
within the framework of following the
cdc guidelines
to get children back to school and i've
been saying that
for months and months that the default
position
should be to the best of our ability
provide the resources
to the local areas so that children
can get back to school provided they
have
fundamental safety measures like mask
wearing
and things like that that may require
additional resources to the local school
districts
at the the default position dr fauci of
many of the teachers unions appears to
be
we're not going to go back into a
guaranteed that there is safety but i
know that's not a discussion
that really falls into your area of
purview but what
does is the who the world health
organization you addressed the w-h-o
last week you said that
the united states was re-entering the
w.h.o
uh you have also said that the united
states is going to participate in the
vaccine sharing program
with the who so a couple of questions uh
first of all when it comes to the who
are you certain that they are operating
as an independent body
and not on the behalf of china as was
alleged by the last administration
and then secondly entering the vaccine
sharing program
what effect will that have on the united
states ability
to get vaccines out to people when we're
already having problems doing that
well john thank you for posing the
question in that way and i hopefully
get a clear explanation first of all if
you
listened which i think you did but if
not everybody had the opportunity
to carefully look at the words that i
used when i made the announcement
that we will be rejoining the who
at least twice during that announcement
i made it very clear
that we would expect reforms in who
and we would take those reforms very
seriously
next we said we were very much in favor
of the investigation of the origins
of this virus so although we willingly
said that we want to rejoin the who
and be part of the international
community we made it very clear
and i was representing the president on
that announcement
that reforms are going to be taken very
seriously by us
so that answers your first question
now i forgot your second question
it was on the it was on joining the
who's vaccine sharing program we're
having enough trouble in this country
getting vaccine to americans if we join
this vaccine sharing program will that
exacerbate the problem
well uh thank you john for asking the
question
when we say we're joining kovacs we're
not saying
that we are going to give them
allocations
that were our allocations we said that
we would participate
in making sure that there's some equity
globally for countries that can't afford
it
there are a number of ways of doing that
one is to provide financial resources
to the program to develop vaccines
from other companies or even the
companies that we're dealing with
to be able to get vaccine doses to them
it doesn't mean we're going to take the
vaccine doses
that were allocated to us and give to
them the other thing is
if it turns out that in our contractual
relationships
we overshoot and we have even more
vaccine than we can use
there always would be the consideration
be a nice problem to have
now that would be but that is
conceivable that that would happen
so just make sure the american public
doesn't interpret
that we're going to take vaccine that
was ready to go to new york or chicago
and give it to somebody else that's not
what we're talking about dr fauci it
also seems like the goal posts keep
moving
uh you know we know california is having
problems we're talking about additional
strains and
and and all of us are trying to do what
it takes to stay safe
and we all wear our masks we hope that
most people are wearing their masks
but now we're hearing we should wear two
where do you stand on that do i if i go
to the grocery store do i wear two do i
wear three
is it safer to wear eight where does it
stop
the discussion is changing not the goal
post
so the cdc doesn't officially
recommend wearing double masks
what they're saying is you know it would
be a good start
if everybody wears at least one mask
i think that would be important so the
cdc recommendations
have not changed what we're trying to do
is to get individuals who are not
wearing masks to wear masks
and dr freddie can i just get one really
quick answer to the following question
governor cuomo of new york said today
that it's going to take six to nine
months to get everybody vaccinated or at
least to the point where you get hurt
immunity but he can't wait that long
to open the economy back up he's got
competing pressures here what would you
suggest
well i think you don't you don't
necessarily have to have an all or none
phenomenon i speak with
governor cuomo frequently and what he is
trying to do is to make a balance
between what's best
for the public health at the same time
as addressing the serious
impact that would have on the economy
of new york state and new york city
obviously as
an important part of new york state and
what one can do is you can continue
to have public health measures that
would be appropriate for the amount of
infection at the same time of gradually
opening up the economy so you wearing a
mask
keeping distance avoiding congregate
settings doing things like washing hands
as frequently as you can
you can have a great impact on the
dynamics of the outbreak and do that at
the same time
that you're gradually opening up your
economy quite frankly john
that's what we were saying months and
months ago when we were trying to reopen
the economy with the guidelines that we
had put out that unfortunately
were not uniformly followed all right so
dr faust you find a final final because
real quick you just said you talked to
governor cuomo often so if he called you
today and said i've got a positivity
rate below one percent
i've got a lot of people vaccinated i
can do you think it's safe
to to reopen at least for 25 capacity
in-person dining
what would you tell them well you know i
would like to hear a little bit more
about what's going on what the dynamics
are
again you don't make policy in a
conversation like you and i
what i would be happy to do is after i
have a conversation with the governor
then talk to you about the things we
discussed but i don't want to do it
before
i have a conversation thanks dr patrick
i appreciate you taking all the
questions
you don't like it you don't last as long
as he has in his positions
when you're negotiating in public
there's no question dr francis great to
see you thanks so much really appreciate
it thank you